oh yes I am wearing the same clothes as
yesterday's video because I'm shooting
two videos and one day to try to be more
efficient and I put some makeup on
because guess what I'm vain
it is Tuesday here on its Grace and it
is time to talk back to you let's do it
let's start with Twitter I was about to
say why is everything feel slowing off
today but that's just because that's
normal
a kid named Tony new person new person
who personally I don't know when a new
person comments on on any of my social
media I praise the crap out of them and
walk them to the edge grace family a kid
named Tony more like there's also a
tiger named Tony so you clearly have the
eye of the tiger in instances of fire
why would you dance through a fire it's
just a complete hazard you've seen
enough YouTube videos to know not to do
that
dance on the area that it's not on fire
full of tips super bright eat my busty
queen do they offer that on the menu at
Cinnabon if so - please if we're talking
about your
dirty jangle bits nope Brittany killed
you person to person to person
Brittany queued more like there's a
queue of people to ask you how do you
pronounce that so unique go up your
breath what I just found out a share
birthday with great oh my god aha how
cool I will celebrate with you as we
grow closer and closer to death is my
mic on its vastness new person new
person new person is vastness more like
its grace and grace is brain is also
vast a desert of relatively nothing and
then you think you see something there
and then it's a mirage but there are a
couple camels human but I'm a cream fan
of yours you're super international did
you know that very cool you can't smoke
Korea without narc
now let's go to tumblr Alice Krieger a
new person new person to person Alice
creepier more like I'll list a key girl
Oh
kegels you're the boy club they still
get to go to pre-order the movie now
it's less than 12 days what is today
that today and I click the sound know
what is today today is the fourth
there's only 10 days now
Kefka con-com helpings my hero ah my
body like rejected that sentence to
person to person to person
how BIG's my hero more like how BIG's my
how big is your hero 5 foot 9 you pray
it's still 13 days I'll get to go to God
I love this photo so much and now it's
10 days yeah and also I've put on one of
those horse heads before you get so
sweaty inside them do horses sweat you
know what does sweat memories your dog
is hairless and a twist
ha ha so stupid now is go to youtube
Clara age new person to person to person
Clara age more like Clara check your pH
balance you are you're a pool I'm not
gonna dive on your diving board there's
algae down there
do but boy have you been crying grace
crying sometimes feels really good
especially when it's out of your bum in
a regular fashion Memphian Nick new
person to person to person man quippy on
am more like men queef Anya boo boo boo
Sarah so ugly and sometimes grace is
ugly - only on the inside Catherine
persley - person to person to person
Kathlyn personally more like Catherine
purse your Lily figure that out groovey
print well looks like an Egyptian cat
you know what Egyptians worshiped cats
whoops got into a brain hole thinking
about Pharrell's face well that's it for
talking back to you guys I hope that you
enjoyed today's episode of this I don't
know hello big hearts new person new
person to person a lebesgue heart more
like are you from North Cal because they
say hello there all the time Hannah says
it all the time
and I'm just like are you a 12 year old
boy on the skateboard yes she is I just
answered my own question white mmm pubic
words Grace's editor I understand grace
is getting bigger and doing bigger
things but I'm scared that when she gets
her editor her videos aren't going to be
like her anymore sad face baby I would
never let that happen
why do you think it's taking me so long
to get an editor I don't have one yet
but beby beby
[Music]
and also bit bear couldn't ever do that
to you but if there's someone out there
that knows how to make explosion of a
fart happen behind me wouldn't that be
cool pepper stop
sleep sleep sleep soos